bonjour tout le monde je m'appelle cette
scène
[Musique]
référence dans ma vie on était des
femmes donc la première photo que vous
voyez c'est ma grand mère elle me
ressemble un peu myners
elle était enseignante j'ai j'ai pris
beaucoup d'elle son amour du travail
son amour du partage sa persévérance
elle et les mois on a partagé un lit
jusqu'à mes 18 ans ou 20 ans oui 18 ans
plus tôt et au début j'ai bien aimé
parce que j'étais petit est jamais bien
ces histoires pendant l'adolescence à me
déranger parce que j'avais un petit
téléphone et je voulais envoyer des
messages à mes petits copains mais elle
me laissait pas faire et malgré
l'habitude de me laver vers 3 heures du
matin à chaque fois qu'elle n'avait pas
vraiment envie de dormir
à chaque fois je lui posais la question
pourquoi on la vraie raison c'est
qu'elle n'arrivait pas à dormir qu'elle
voulait que je lui pas mais elle me
disait tu sais jamais quand tu vas te
marrer en un jour et que ton mari train
vers 3 heures du matin tu es obligé de
lui répondre
ma mère mon frère et six autres dans la
salle donc je vais pas dire beaucoup
trop de choses sur ma mère ma mère et
moi nous avons toujours une relation
assez unique assez particulière et je
pense que c'est dû au fait que je suis
la seule fille avec deux autres garçons
et là elle a toujours voulu qu'on
réussisse dans la vie je vais te dire
elle a toujours voulu que ces garçons
réussissent dans la vie
moi j'étais destiné à mon mari a alors
riche et pour aller se régler dans la
vie je sais pas si elle va être contente
que j'ai dit ça mais bon donc ma mère
est ce qui m'a toujours fasciné parce
que elle elle croit elle croyait il
croit toujours que mon bonheur
mavenir dunlop donc entre ma grand mère
qui voulait que je me marie mai qui
voulait aussi que je fasse des grandes
études et ma mère qui voulait que je
trouve un homme riche pour régler mes
problèmes fallait que je me trouve
fallait que je trouve
où est ce que je voulais aller fallait
que je trouve qu est ce que je voulais
faire de ma vie ma mère a toujours dit
que je pouvais aller vivre seul après
mon bac tu as eu ton bac tu sors de la
maison crise que tu veux tu peux même
aller vivre avec ton copain mais tout ce
que tu veux je pense qu'elle a toujours
utilisé ça comme excuse pour que j'ai
pas de petit copain pour que je lui
demande pas de sortir pour tout ça donc
il ment bac et voilà je suis partie de
la raison et donc ça a été et là j'ai
commencé à aller à l'université et j'ai
trouvé j'ai eu un petit travail dans un
centre d'appels de la place où il
fallait que parce que je voulais avoir
une indépendance financière pour le plus
être emploi pour ma mère mais je pense
pas que ça la dérange et tout ce qu'elle
faisait pour moi mais moi j'avais envie
de cette indépendance est quelque chose
que j'ai toujours voulu depuis que je
suis petit et ensuite je suis rentré
dans le monde du travail à ces jeunes
après mon premier après mon premier
travail dans un centre d'appels
j'ai rencontré une amie là bas qu'ils
allaient postuler pour un autre travail
qui m'a dit tu vous parle j'ai postulé
avec mention les prises toutes les deux
ce sera trop générale ce que je savais
pas c'est que elle a fait ça parce
qu'elle était déjà prise et elle était
déjà la responsable mais elle savait
qu'elle allait partir dont six mois et
elle voulait que je sois à la personne
qui allait la remplacer donc j'avais un
travail dans la place d'un travail qui
paie bien et j'avais tout mais c'était
un monde que je connaissais pas il
fallait que je dise oui quand j'avais
envie de dire non
il fallait que j'accepte les remarques
machistes et sexistes des hommes qui
travaillaient dans l'entreprise
il fallait que je m'adapte à un
environnement que je ne connaissais pas
du tout donc cette expérience m'a permis
surtout de me connaître en tant que
personne et en tant que femme elle m'a
permis de savoir les choses que je
voulais dans ma vie que les choses que
je voulais pas elle appelle même à
parler de savoir que j'avais pas envie
de travailler pour quelqu'un d'autre que
j'avais envie d'avoir mon entreprise
vous avez envie de faire quelque chose
je vais me lever le matin et faire mon
emploi du temps donc je pense que l'idée
d'être entrepreneur à ce moment là ne
veut me venaient même pas encore en tête
parce que je connaissais pas le manger
jamais été
mais devant ça donc je parlais beaucoup
à mes cousins et amis des amis à moi de
ce que je voulais faire dans ma vie et
tout ça est un jour j'allais au
restaurant avec une de mes amies elle me
demande d'arrêter de parler de cette
histoire là parce que ça fait longtemps
mais pour moi j'y tiens parce que c'est
l'histoire qui m'a amené où je suis
aujourd'hui elle me pose la question
elle s'appelle yann à elle le pose la
question il me dit mais surtout ton
histoire de devenir designer d'avoir ton
d'entreprise qui pose toujours ou pas
j'ai dit oui j'y pense mais tu sais j'ai
pas encore l'argent je ne sais pas et
tout ça elle me dis qu'est-ce combien tu
es en poche et je lui dis la somme est
là est marraine au marché de sandaga et
j'avais quarante mille francs je vous
dis vers 40 mille francs
donc là avec ses 40 mille francs là j'ai
commencé ce qui m'a amené devant vous
aujourd'hui
donc on a acheté des perles on l'a
acheté tout ça et j'ai commencé à faire
décoller l avant à les vendre un bon
travail et on suit les gens
s'intéressaient beaucoup plus à ce que
je portais pas ce que je fais mes
propres vêtements et j'utilise beaucoup
le toucher africains donc les gens me
disaient toujours oui mais moi j'aime
bien le collier mais jouer en europe et
tout ça et j'ai dit mais bon pourquoi
pas avec mon allée voir mon tailleur et
faire des dizaines et comment si peu à
peu donc on allait ce design les cousins
m'aide à monter une fan facebook et ce
qu'il fallait c'était un nombre donc
jamais me martinique et que j'aime
beaucoup qui et comment faire pour moi
qui me
avec qui je parle et je lui dis bon
c'est ça l'idée donc je veux faire une
marque de vêtements avec çà çà çà étude
est elle touchée africain j'ai cherché
un nom je suis ses erreurs donc j'ai
cherché un an la base ou loue tout ça
mais j'avais pas avoir ce bon et là il
me dit belliard points après à des gens
qu'ils s'arrangent pour dire délia
rebella c'est facile à dire si belliard
et là il me dit belga il veut dit
belliard et il me dit ça mais des cris
de joie et parce que tu es quelqu'un de
très joyeuses et parce que tu as reçu le
goya
donc j'aime le monde j'en parle je
demande à un ami et je dis beaucoup mes
cousins parce qu'il ya eu deux personnes
dans ma vie qui s'ils n'étaient pas là
je serais pas là où je suis aujourd'hui
c'est un mes cousins qui est de la soeur
d appel elle a mille et un autre qui
s'appelle et l'âge et donc il me met en
rapport avec un gars fils qui me fait le
design donc bellia est là et là on a
commencé ses dessins accès des
chaussures c'est tout ce qui pour monlam
la la mode africain anc on commence plus
de un peu et moi j'adore dire que je
fais partie de ces entreprenant là qui
sont là grâce à facebook parce que ma
première hop je les vends du grâce à
facebook et pays répartis partout dans
le monde grâce à internet grâce à
facebook au nom de notre première
boutique et là je commence à avoir une
stabilité financière et là il fallait
que je dit mon travail en tant que
salarié salariés pour me convaincre
on a consacré sur bellia chose qui n'a
pas été facile parce que je vous ai dit
plutôt que j'habitais seul donc j'ai dû
sortir de là où je vivais avant parce
que j'allais plus me permettre de payer
le salaire allait partager un lit avec
mes cousins préféré et ensuite me
redonner et l'institut financière et
quand j'ai vu ça je suis parti et là
c'est les deux boutiques qu'on a ouvert
pour bellion et quand j'ai eu la
stabilité financière que je cherchais je
suis parti vers la chose qui meurent ce
qu'on lui qui me fait vivre et tout ça
c'est le droit des femmes parce que j'ai
toujours toujours toujours valoriser la
femme
donc j'ai commencé à travailler sur des
projets qui pourraient aider la femme en
général j'ai lancé ce qu'on appelle le
bélier a exclu en poule et c'était un
projet pour aider les femmes de lampes
ou la avoir assez d'argent
financièrement pour pouvoir aider leur
fille pour qu'elle puisse rester à
l'école s'il faut ou pour qu'elle ne
tombe pas dans le mariage forcé et
ensuite en 2016 un faisan programme le
monde et la fellowship vient rencontrer
une personne une personne que j'aime
beaucoup qui s'appelle fatou bourg et là
on a monté ce qui s'appelle le led
comptes qui a un camp de leadership et
d'entrepreneuriat pour les femmes donc
ce qu'on fait là bas c'est on est les
femmes à se trouver à savoir qu'elle
peut faire des choses d'elle même à
savoir qu'elles n'ont pas besoin
d'attendre les autres pour remplir
certaines choses à aller vers les
projets chaud surtout l'information au
sénégal c'est que on dit tout le temps
aux gens qu'il faut beaucoup d'argent
pour commencer un projet donc alors à
les aider à s'organiser à faire tout ça
et après le
après le après le lait est content on a
on est parti dans plusieurs régions au
sénégal pour éduquer les les pas éduqué
j'aime pas utiliser ce mot mais pour
partager ce qu'on a fait pour leur
donner l'exemple qu'on ait des jeunes
femmes
nous sommes là et nous avons fait ceci
et cela
et là je vais vous parler
d'après tout ce que j'ai fait de ma vie
pourquoi il est important de vivre pour
soi
je vais vous raconter de petites
histoires de ma vie un jour avant
l'ouverture de la deuxième boutique la
veille je rentre chez moi je vous ai dit
que je vous explique je vis seul mais
enfin je vais avec mes deux chats et
c'est mes enfants le gardien m'attendais
mais de pied ferme du style elle se
touche en effet je n'arrivais pas à te
voir toute cette semaine tu rentré très
tard jeudi 2 les champs train de
travailler
ils étaient sidérés il m'a dit tu
travailles j'ai dit ah oui il m'a dit
j'ai dit si je travaille il me dit tu
sais moi j'ai dit m
je comprends que j'étais outrée et je ne
comprenais pas là où il voulait en venir
et là il me dit il m'a juste interpellé
parce qu'il voulait de l'argent pour sa
femme qui venait d'accoucher et je lui
dis mais pourquoi est ce que tu penses
que je travaille pas comment tu penses
que je paye mon loi et tout ça et vous
savez ce qu'il pensait il pensait que
j'étais une prostituée
je n'ai pas de problème avec ce métier
c'est un choix mais c'est moi qui me bat
pour sortir de ce concours de femmes
dépendantes me voilà résumée à ça et la
deuxième petite histoire c'est que
j'étais à new york et j'étais dans un
restaurant j'adore manger et j'étais
dans un restaurant et
et dans le resto jmil photo de mon plat
sur facebook et là quelques uns qui
m'envoie un message pour me demander
mais pourquoi tu mets jamais la photo de
l'homme qui te paie tous ces endroits là
[Musique]
je pense que j'ai mis un statut facebook
ensuite pour parler de ça et c'est tous
à tous ces exemples ci pour revenir sur
le fait en tant que femme je ne
comprends pas pourquoi est ce que on est
toujours réduit à ça on est toujours
réduit au fait que notre réussite dépend
forcément dans l'âme derrière toujours
on nous rappelle pour être réussie mais
bon on sait ce soit le père tual prépa
soit le mari et on est tous temps chargé
à penser ça arme et je vais parler de
réussir pour soi ça peut sembler égoïste
parce qu'on dit souvent qu ont réçu pour
sa famille on veut issue pour tours
beaucoup de charme le prend comme
exemple en disant qu'un statut elle a
réussi sa vie et les jeunes est là et a
brisé partout dans le monde
elle a fait tellement de choses que
beaucoup de gens jeunes filles de son
âge ne peuvent pas faire pourtant pour
ma mère est pour beaucoup de gens que je
connais ma vie n'est pas une réussite
parce que je suis pas marié j'inspire
pas à me marier je ne me réveille pas
chaque matin en me disant
[Musique]
si je remets pas demain je vais mourir
c'est parce c'est pas c'est pas mon
essence j'inspire pas à cette ville ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de vivre une vie
saine de faire en sorte que ma famille
mes amis et les gens tu content pour moi
sont fiers de moi de faire des bonds
réaction est de me baser sur ces choses
là et surtout surtout de réussir pour
moi donc c'est les choses qui selon les
sources et les choses vers lesquels je
tends pour terminer j'ai un message pour
cette petite fille je veux que cette
petite fille et ses rêves qu'elle se dit
que quand elle sera grande
elle pourra devenir danseuse on va
commencer par sa pilote astronautes
architectes tout ce qu'elle veut que son
bonheur c'est à elle de forger que c'est
à elle de dessiner sa vie que c'est à
elle si elle veut être la femme de
quelqu'un et être heureuse pour ça
qu'elle doit choisir sa elle même parce
qu'il ya une chose dans cette vie si on
vit si on vit avec ce que les autres ont
écrit pour non on va être malheureux
mais tous des gens non au travail le
matin et reviennent et est leur vie
parce qu'ils ont choisi une vie que les
autres m
ils ont choisi une vie que les autres
apprécient pour eux et ils n'ont pas
choisi la vie qui volent et donc ses
petites filles je me qu'elle découvre le
monde comme elle qu'elle traite les gens
de la façon qu'elle aimerait être
traitée et surtout surtout qu'elle sache
qu'elle a le droit de vivre une vie
assuré qu'elle sache qu'il n'est pas
même pour ramasser la vaisselle et faire
le linge pour son petit frère il peut le
faire
qu'elle sache qu'elle vit pas pour être
derrière un nom et qu'elle sache que la
vie l'attend est latent avec beaucoup
beaucoup
beaucoup de bonheur cette petite fille
c'est moi et elle sait tout ça donc ce
message c'est un petit vieux petite
fille dans son monde merci
[Applaudissements]